Денисе, назвіть себе і
розкажіть чим саме ви займаєтесь.
Робота там аналітиків,
журналістів, вона не сексі.
Це доволі нудна справа.
Ах! Не бачу!
Наполегливість, терплячість
і висока, висока працездатність.
І готовність до того, що все не вийде швидко.
А 95% — це складна, нудна аналітична робота.
І світ після неї якщо і змінюється,
то надзвичайно повільно.
[російською] Так? Ну так!
Ну, думаю, годину-півтори.
І так кожен вечір. Телефонує дружина
десь завжди о восьмій — пів на дев'яту,
робить такий глибокий видих:
«Ти сьогодні знову пізно? І ти завжди
обіцяєш, що ти за годину—півтори приїдеш,
а потім приїжджаєш за три—чотири години».
Бо чому так? Бо це ще до того,
хто такий розслідувач.
Розслідувач, та й взагалі журналіст:
у нього немає і не може бути роботи
умовно з дев'ятої до шостої.
Типу ти о шостій клацаєш пальцем:
«Все я більше не журналіст, я пішов». Такого не буває!
Тобі просто або цікаво все,
що відбувається навколо, або ні.
І от якщо тобі цікаво,
то цей процес не має меж часових.
Ти 24 на 7 про щось думаєш,
щось дивишся, десь їздиш,
з кимось говориш, копаєшся в якихось
там базах, тендерах і так далі.
А чого тут так достобіса тачок, ти не знаєш?
Розслідування потрібні тому, що вони збільшують
ризики робити якесь повне лайно
для тих, хто має повноваження його робити.
Не викорінюють його, збільшують ризики.
Ці ж, здається, зверталися,
і їм відмовили в наданні земельної ділянки?
Я думаю, що оцей буде брати, дерев'яний.
А оце який? Цей прикольніший!
Наче за один день побудований.
Я так розумію, це не сам храм побудований.
А! і цей, до речі, можна.
Мене дивує, кажу, що вони
не просто храм побудували,
вони ще й всю територію забрали собі.
Цей парканчик? Та це зимовий сад, знаєш!
Ми займаємося викриттям
чогось, що хотіли би приховати,
і своєю місією ми визначаємо контролювати,
щоб українська влада
добре робила свою роботу,
і звертати увагу, коли
робота робиться не добре,
і, власне, показувати такі кейси,
коли влада недопрацьовує,
і намагатися змінити це,
враховуючи всі наші журналістські можливості і все,
що ми можемо зробити як журналісти.
Ми стежимо за тим, щоб політики добре працювали,
щоб вони дотримувалися принципів політичної культури,
і працювали не в своїх інтересах,
а в інтересах виборців.
Щоб електоральна демократія
перетворювалася в учасницьку.
Тобто, щоб люди жили не тільки днем виборів,
коли ти йдеш голосувати і робиш свій вибір,
а щоб постійно стежили за тими рішеннями,
які ухвалює влада,
долучалися до прийняття рішень,
моніторили як працюють обрані ними політики.
У нас є на сайті «ЧЕСНО» окремий інструмент,
ми його вже думали видалити,
тому що надії було мало.
Інструмент з кнопкодавами,
де зібрані всі-всі відео з дуже давніх часів,
підписані: за що було голосування,
хто кнопкодавив.
Зеленський обіцяв,
що ця Рада не буде кнопкодавити. Так?
В попередніх Радах вони, кнопкодави, не ховалися,
а в цій Раді, коли ми впіймали перших «слуг»,
далі вони вже так, з обережністю.
І дуже продумували такі цікаві, прикольні схеми.
Наприклад, розкладали газетки
на пульти і натискали під газетками.
Навіть змайстрували такий
пристрій для кнопкодавства.
Наскладали груду книжечок
і так от стегном штовхаєш ці книжки,
кут тисне на кнопку:
«Це ж якби не я, це — книжки».
Але зверху воно виглядає настільки
смішно і низько, можете собі уявити.
Або, так от, прикриваючись, з-під ліктя,
тобто різні способи.
І ти дивишся зверху на це все,
коли вже наш оператор приносить матеріал,
і ти розумієш: просто дно!
Це виглядає дуже смішно!
А вони не гребують, вони це роблять.
Що ще мене страшенно дратує:
що окремі народні депутати або окремі політики
називають це стеженням і
втручанням умовно в особисте життя.
Камон! Ми, знову таки, просто катаємося Києвом
і дивимося, спостерігаємо за тим,
що відбувається, і шукаємо щось цікаве.
Ми, не дай Боже, не встромляємо
якісь прослушки і камери в одяг,
в приватне майно, в машини.
Врятуй Боже!
Але просто стояти під рестораном і дивитися,
як народні депутати порушують карантин,
за який вони ж самі притопили,
у цьому немає нічого незаконного.
У цьому немає ніякого умовно стеження,
чи як вони це називають?
Мовляв, журналісти перебрали
на себе роль правоохоронців
і займаються НСРД —
негласна слідчо-розшукова діяльність.
Типу блін! Пацани! Я не знаю.
Читайте закони і просто
не зашкварюйтеся, і не творіть якої фігні.
Спочатку ми робили
журналістську роботу
і повідомляли про те,
що ми вважаємо злочинами.
І це добре працювало перший рік-два,
чотирнадцятий-п'ятнадцятий [роки],
а потім це перестало працювати.
Реагують тільки на зраду.
Щось добре поширити? НІ!
Якщо Аваков зробив якусь фігню,
посилює своє відомство, то Аваков несеться.
Тобто зрада поки працює.
Мені здається, що тут більше питання
конвертувати цю зраду у відповідальність.
Бо в нас, розумієте, таке ставлення стало.
Викрили корупціонера:
«Та ладно, йому нічого не буде!»
Викрили іншого, таке от!
А коли показувати цей
процес настання відповідальності,
дай Бог, щоб когось посадили —
такі зміни, воно трохи цікавіше.
Очевидно, що є історії, коли у когось
там вкрали машину чи ошукали шахраї,
і для цієї людини навколо
цього може крутитися життя.
Ми намагаємося зробити так,
щоб ті історії, за які ми беремося,
бо нас мало, у нас маленький ресурс,
щоб вони відкривали отакі пласти,
які стосуються якомога більшої кількості людей.
Щоб кожна людина, яка подивилася
цю історію, зрозуміла що і як працює,
і що вона зможе зробити: на кого натиснути,
куди написати заяву, зрозуміти
хто відповідальний за це.
Тобто тема вибирається з огляду на те,
що зроблено не так, хто недопрацьовує
і наскільки багатьох людей це стосується.
Ми дослідили статки всього
вищого духовенства трьох церков.
По деяким священнослужителям
ми були, м'яко кажучи, здивовані,
коли, наприклад, митрополит
якоїсь української області
володіє кількома шикарними квартирами,
маєтками на 600, на 700,
на 800 квадратів, на 1200 квадратів.
З ким можна поспілкуватися
стосовно відведення землі від храму?
Чи вона відведена, чи ні?
Митрополит Донеччини, у нього
цей будинок знаходиться в Пісках,
це недалеко від Донецького аеропорту.
І тоді, коли були активні бойові дії на сході,
тоді було зруйновано фактично
всі дачі, весь район,
всі Піски було зруйновано,
окрім цього будинку.
Має певні зв'язки з сепаратистами,
але при цьому він регулярно
їздить на українську територію,
тобто на нашу, сюди, в Київ.
Він входить в Священний Синод
Російської православної церкви в Україні.
І, дійсно, ми зрозуміли, що походження
цього майна дуже часто викликає питання.
Тому, що люди не дуже розуміють:
є документи, нема документів.
Кожен зранку прокинувся, з вікна подивився:
«Щось будується? — Ну гаразд, мабуть законно».
Тобто вони собі вирішили,
що у них тут буде храм.
Просто взяли, привезли
будматеріали, почали будувати.
Ні в кого не спитали дозволу,
не погодили ні з ким.
Ну от уяви:
у тебе тут будинок, ти тут живеш,
одного ранку ти прокидаєшся,
а в тебе тут храм вже стоїть.
І питання: чи треба він тут, чи не треба,
чи хтось просив їх про це? Не знаю.
І зносити це ніхто вже не буде,
бо як тільки почнуть зносити,
одразу прибіжать віряни,
і скажуть, що це замах на святиню.
Робота журналістів-розслідувачів
досі залишається небезпечною в Україні,
у таких країнах, не тільки в Україні,
ми бачимо, що і в європейських країнах,
на журналістів нападають, вбивають.
Тому усвідомлення, що небезпека —
це частина твоєї щоденної роботи,
це теж необхідна річ.
Ми починаємо. Ні!
Ще не починаємо викликати інтерес.
Але зараз вони побачать відблиски,
що у нас світяться тут камери.
О! Вже починають! Привіт, хлопці.
Ну так, ми вже привернули їх увагу.
Вони починають обговорювати
плани евакуації гостей з ресторану.
Ну один просто вийшов з камерою.
— Що тебе найбільше дратує?
— Зараз?
— Та взагалі, подібне.
Коли ти фіксуєш щось цікаве,
а потім тобі доводиться
кілька годин чекати,
поки це цікаве завершиться.
От як, наприклад, зараз.
Просто це знову таки до розмови того, що...
Це як в тому мемі:
як свою роботу бачу я,
як мою роботу бачить мама,
як мою роботу бачать друзі.
Так от, може здаватися,
що це постійно якийсь екшн,
двіж, погоні, стеження і так далі,
а насправді ні.
Скільки ми сидимо вже? Хвилин 40?
І скільки ми ще просидим?
У мене є взагалі таке відчуття,
що якби не ефір,
то робота над розслідуванням
тривала б десь років чотири—п'ять
і не завершувалася б ніколи.
Тому що це як ремонт.
Це не можна закінчити.
Це можна тупо припинити. Все!
Це, до речі, для журналістів,
які фахово в це занурюються,
така протилежна проблема —
вони не зупиняються.
Ти ж знаходиш ще щось,
ще щось, ще щось, ще щось.
Потім тобі про все це хочеться розповісти.
А якщо ти вчасно не кажеш:
«Ого! Все, все, стоп!» —
то кожне розслідування перетворюється
на п'ятитомник, якусь дисертацію,
не Кивину, а таку, нормальну.
Все, щасливо!
От що цікаво: людині 23 роки,
вона тусить не на дискотеках ввечері,
не по клубах, не по барах,
вона тусить тут.
Я просто за це люблю ще те, чим займаюсь.
Бо взагалі в цю професію і
конкретно в розслідування ідуть фанатики.
Треба бути божевільним, щоб цим займатися,
мабуть, не люблячи або
просто як ремеслом, як роботою.
Це треба цим жити, потрібно горіти.
Хочеться знайти якусь сенсацію,
щось класне зняти, щось круте розказати.
І це постійне відчуття тебе
так тримає в тонусі постійно. Це класно!
Хтось, підписуючи якийсь папірець,
що вплине на життя всіх, подумає: «Та ну його!»
От ми маємо показувати
оці болісні точки, у нас така робота.
І я пишаюся, що ми її робимо.
«Рух ЧЕСНО» дев'ять років боровся за кнопкодавство.
Ми намоніторили більше 2000 випадків
неперсонального голосування в парламенті. Так?
Нарешті запровадили сенсорну кнопку,
яка унеможливлює кнопкодавство.
І якась херня не відбудеться,
і ми про це навіть не дізнаємось,
але є моментик.
Так само розумію людей, яким це не подобається.
Тому, що вони хочуть мовчки
далі не робити свою роботу,
і щоб ніхто на це не звертав увагу.
Але є журналісти-розслідувачі
і нас багато, і, на щастя, ми натхненні.